[Musique]
là c'est le moment où vous vous demandez
pourquoi l'équipe de rendez-vous au
bistrot est au petit déjeuner pas de
bistrot buissonniers ce samedi je vous
rassure non plus tôt l' envie de
profiter du début du printemps pour vous
emmener en balade
on vous en maintenant rando dans le jura
on est ici à baume les messieurs en
village bien connu et ce samedi on va
vous faire découvrir un autre village
grange surboum la lega par contre le
bistrot c'est là au 1 allée non non non
ça va pas être possible
bah les gars vous venez pas
[Musique]
tous
nous voici arrivés à grand sur boom où
vivent une centaine d'habitants heureux
[Musique]
nous avons rendez vous avec michel et
béatrice qui ont tout plaqué pour
changer radicalement de vie il ya un an
et ouvrir un bistrot dortoir michel et
béatrice bonjourbonjour d'euros
d'avancés enchanté c'est magnifique chez
vous quand on voit bistrot dortoir le
nom de votre bistrot on se pose
forcément la question qu'est ce que
c'est que ce concept c'est un endroit où
on peut venir boire quelque chose du
matin au soir on peut manger sur place
le midi et certains soirs et surtout
l'avantagé de dormir sur place
c'est du coup est ce qu'on pourra manger
parce qu'avec la montée ça creuse
rabiatou vous allez pouvoir manger mais
on va faire les courses avant mais je
vous suis on y va alors sacré problème
par la route de nadal
on va faire les courses habituelles chez
nos producteurs locaux
[Musique]
berdos est important qu'au bistrot
dortoir y ait que des produits quasiment
locaux bio bien sûr que c'est important
parce que déjà c'est faire vivre les
producteurs locaux
c'est parce que rennes n'en a pas vu je
ne sais pas pour répondre à une mode la
cuisine c'est une patiente
[Musique]
après chez vous dans votre ferme on a vu
vos produits à la grange du jura ce
choix de circuits courts c'était quoi
c'était un pari au départ c'était une
volonté d'être complètement indépendant
oui c'est un challenge au début un donc
c'était parce que je m'en sortais pas
économiquement donc j'ai plus le choix
de vendre en direct ça sera fait du jour
au lendemain
et donc quand on a ce pour deux raisons
donc les raisons économiques de jeanine
l'intermédiaire les clients s'y retrouve
je me retrouve est aussi d'aller
jusqu'au bout de mon produit c'est pas
évident parce que ces deux métiers
différents du coup quasiment c'est
complètement différent donc un c'est la
production et l'autre c'est être en
contact avec les clients
est ce que vous êtes un éleveur heureux
aujourd'hui aujourd'hui oui parce que
après avec du recul c'est un jeu ça fait
20 ans que je suis installé au jour au
jour d'aujourd'hui maintenant oui avec
le recul mais c'est vrai que c'est passé
des périodes assez difficile mais bon
voilà c'est derrière et maintenant ben
voilà l'avenir
merci beaucoup rappellent je voulais
parce qu'il y avait entre et ce qui
m'attend au cul c'est bien on va
[Musique]
woods s'est excusé avec béatrice ouais
bon jour pour pardon jour de danger
enchantée donc voilà faut goûter un
s'est massé mon petit test à michel
jamais une question qu'est-ce qui a fait
que vous êtes installés ici à granges
sur un gros coup de coeur en arrivant
fois un site époustouflant une maison à
vendre et on s'est lancé dans l'aventuré
on est amis depuis longtemps et bing y a
rien d'autre à dire
jean vous vous êtes vichy c'est un
village qui est aussi dynamique où c'est
un village qui est leur un peu parce que
justement on est un peu perdu un peu
loin de tout ici loin du tout un village
qui est très dynamique bombe à la
fromagerie on à jura faune jurafaune qui
amène du monde on a une miellerie qui se
monte ensuite on a des gîtes aussi mais
oui c'est pas mal quand vous avez quand
même pas mal un message ça prend de
l'ampleur je t'ouvre et ben c'est très
bien et un bistrot dortoir en plus à ses
mélodies
l'aca ses jambes et bien merci et ben
alaoui
pourquoi ces deux journées
[Musique]
on ne pouvait pas venir ici à granges
sur boom sans venir au parc dédié aux
rapaces jurafaune ça sera ouvert d'ici
une quinzaine de jours vous serez prêt
est basse et bomba voyez on attend plus
beau ici dans le jura